wer hat die beiden ostsee-pipelines in
die Luft gejagt wer ist für diesen Gas
leckt Villa verantwortlich am Montag
kommt es in beiden Pipelines nordstream
1 und Nord Stream 2 zu starken
druckabfällen die Ursache insgesamt
Dreiecks in den Pipelines so die große
Frage jetzt wie konnten diese Lex
entstehen der Verdacht ganz klar
Sabotage
das sind die ersten Aufnahmen der
schwedischen Küstenwache vom Gasleck der
beiden pipelines-nordstream 1 und 2 gut
zu erkennen das Gas blubbert einfach so
in die Ostsee es bilden sich gewaltige
Strudel der größte gaswirbel hat ein
Durchmesser von mehr als einem Kilometer
eines der lex an der Pipeline Nord
Stream 2 liegt in der Nähe der dänischen
Insel Bornholm die Betreiber der
Pipeline haben einen Druckabfall von 105
auf 7 bar festgestellt
Kampfflieger der dänischen Streitkräfte
entdecken insgesamt drei gaslacks an den
Pipelines um die Gebiete herum wurden
Verbotszonen eingerichtet um die
Sicherheit für den schiffs- und
Flugverkehr zu garantieren noch ist
völlig unklar wie es zu den Lex kommen
konnte zwei Explosionen die am Montag in
Schweden und Dänemark an mehreren
Messstationen registriert wurden
sprechen gegen einen Unfall die
schwedische Premierministerin Magdalena
Anderson glaubt nicht an ein Unglück wir
haben schwedische Informationen aber
auch Informationen aus unseren Kontakten
mit Dänemark und sind auf dieser
Grundlage zu dem Schluss gekommen dass
dies wahrscheinlich eine vorsätzliche
Handlung ist es handelt sich also
vermutlich um Sabotage der
US-amerikanische Außenminister Anthony
blinken äußert sich ebenfalls zu den Lex
es gibt erste Berichte die darauf
hindeuten dass dies das Ergebnis eines
Angriffs oder eine Art Sabotage sein
könnte aber das sind erste Berichte und
es gibt noch keine Bestätigung aber
sollte es so sein ist das eindeutig in
niemandes Interesse
auch aus Sicht deutscher
Sicherheitskreise spricht vieles für
Sabotage für einen Sabotageakt einer
solchen Größe kommen allerdings nur
wenige staatliche Akteure in Frage wer
wirklich dahinter stecken könnte noch
völlig ungewiss
und dazu sind wir jetzt mit dr Frank
Umbach verbunden Experte für
sicherheits- und Energiepolitik an der
Uni Bonn die dänische
Ministerpräsidentin sagt es sei kaum zu
glauben bzw
es kann eigentlich nicht geglaubt werden
dass das ein Zufall sein kann zwei Lex
gleichzeitig was glauben sie ihrer
Meinung nach spricht das für einen
Sabotageakt
ja guten Morgen ja auch aus meiner Sicht
spricht das für einen Sabotage Akt und
im Wesentlichen aus sechs Gründen
erstens wir haben es mit drei
unterschiedlichen Lex zu tun
die innerhalb von wenigen weniger als 24
Stunden aufgetreten sind also relativ
zeitgleich zweitens die Entfernung
zwischen diesen Lex beträgt mehr als 50
Kilometer
das also hier eine natürliche Ursache
ein Erdbeben oder sowas entstanden
möglicherweise passiert sein soll ist
von daher wenig
glaubwürdig mal abgesehen davon dass
diese Gegend nur nicht wirklich als
Erdbebengebiet bisher bekannt gewesen
ist dann das Ausmaß der Schäden also
normalerweise kleinere Leckagen können
immer mal auftreten gerade auch bei
älteren Pipeline wie entstehen meistens
dann auch an diesen Schweißnähten der
Pipelines da fließt aber dann so wenig
Gas raus dass das normalerweise auch an
der Oberfläche des
eben dann überhaupt nicht sichtbar ist
also insoweit spricht das Ausmaß auch
dagegen dann gibt es auch den
politischen Kontext ja die erste
Erklärung die vom Kreml offiziell
abgegeben worden ist war im Grunde
genommen gleich gegenüber der Erklärung
warum man die nordstream 1 Pipeline die
Versorgung Ende August eingestellt hat
und die offizielle Begründung ist eben
dass sein alles Technische Schäden und
die Folge der westlichen
Sanktionspolitik die Russland in der Tat
seit ungefähr juli verstärkt mehr auch
im Hinblick auf die Abnahme von Öl und
gaseinnahmen und dann gibt es noch ein
weiteren Kontext der Verein in Polen
natürlich große Besorgnis ausgelöst hat
und das ist eine Pipeline die von
Norwegen über Dänemark nach Polen geht
die sogenannte Baltic Pipeline und die
verläuft südlich von Bornholm und kreuzt
unter Wasser die beiden nordstream
Pipeline und diese Pipeline wird jetzt
in den wenigen Tagen im Oktober erstmals
in Betrieb genommen und ist für Russland
ein besonders großes Ärgernis weil Polen
sich damit endgültig von russischen
Gaslieferungen unabhängig macht und
diese Entscheidung ist seit Jahren
getroffen worden lange auch vor dem
ukraine-konflikt und dann haben wir
dieses cia-warnung im Vorfeld bereits
gehabt und das alles dazu dass niemand
an irgendwelche technischen Unfälle
glaubt die eben nicht erklärbar sind
sondern tatsächlich hier mit einem
Sabotage Art gerechnet sozusagen nach
oder damit gerechnet werden muss ja und
wer kommt dafür in Frage wem würde es
nutzen dass beide Leitungen ausfallen
und eigentlich gibt es nur einen Akteur
der von dem man das vermuten kann und
das ist Russland
russland hat diese Fähigkeiten auch als
staatlicher Akteur ein anderes Beispiel
ist die NATO macht sich seit vielen
Jahren Sorgen weil wir beobachtet haben
beispielsweise dass es sehen Manöver gab
spezielle U-Boote auch die zum Beispiel
in einem Konfliktfall die
Unterseekabel zwischen Europa und den
USA unter dem Wasser unter dem Meer
entsprechend in einem Konfliktfall
Kappen können und insoweit auch das
gesamte politische Umfeld wo wir jetzt
ja jetzt mit einer Eskalation des
Konfliktes in ukraine-konflikt zu tun
haben bedeutet aber auch eine Eskalation
um den Druck auch noch weiter zu erhöhen
gegenüber Deutschland und dem Westen die
Sanktionen aufzuheben keine schweren
Waffen zu liefern etc es ist von daher
zu vermuten dass es auch ein klar
politische Signal an den Westen ist sagt
Frank Umbach Experte für
Energiesicherheit und Sicherheitspolitik
an der Uni Bonn danke Ihnen
bitte schön
[Musik]